comme elle le fait tous les jours
tamarins une intervenante communautaire
va rencontrer les personnes âgées qui
ont besoin des domiciles bonjour c'est
l'affairé de votre nom vous avez besoin
de cette journée là il rencontre monique
86 ans et son mari le rang qui en à 88
même s'ils sont bien conscients que leur
état de santé s'est détérioré au cours
des derniers mois ce qui souhaitent le
plus au monde c'est de rester ensemble
dans leur maison et ce qu'ils veulent
c'est du soutien de missiles n'osant
fine on n'est pas bien loin mais un
travail sur pas toujours ici pour nous a
aidés et puis ces 4 on manque de coffre
pour manger une fois on peut marquer dix
les deux afin d'abattre en dépit de tout
pour elle le gouvernement n'en fait pas
assez
pourquoi il dit qu'eads et améliorer l'
aide à domicile dans notre vin bière
avant des services dans l'ouest de l'île
où ils habitent les budgets alloués à
l'aide des domiciles selon nos calculs
ont diminué de 10% cette année par
rapport à l'an passé ce qui se traduit
par cent mille heures de services
privant à moins cette année et tamar en
voit les effets sur le terrain
elle affirme même avoir rencontré une
dame de 85 ans qui attend depuis huit
mois de l'aide pour prendre un bain
j'étais chacun je pense je suis encore
choqué c'est important que je fais me
suivait avec le célé c'est parce que
c'est pas normal on ne devrait pas dans
l'ensemble des établissements santé de
l'île de montréal toujours selon nos
calculs les budgets de l'aide à domicile
ont baissé cette année de près de 9%
une somme équivalant à 9 millions pas
étonnant donc que les effets de ces
réductions budgétaires se fassent sentir
un peu partout à montréal comme ici dans
cet organisme communautaire de l'est de
l'île ce qu'on constate en fait c'est
que les services de maintien à domicile
qui sont requis pour nos clients
vieillissant particulièrement la
clientèle qui vit en hlm celle qu'on
connaît le mieux ils peuvent attendre
parfois de 6,1 à pour obtenir des
services des bains ménages
jeanine fontaine elhadj attente près de
1 avant d'obtenir de l'aide à domicile
de son celle ci il vous met réalise que
vous attendez vous attendez c'est pas
courageuse est pas pour ceux circulant
un peu mais ça prend beaucoup de temps
je vous dis pas ce que je lui dis que
quand ce ne sont pas les délais
d'attentes qui sont en cause ce sont les
services qui sont carrément copie on a
d'ailleurs rencontré une dame de 82 ans
qui en plus d'attendre pour de l'aide
aux bains depuis plusieurs mois a perdu
récemment l'aide au ménage qu'elle
recevait pourtant depuis dix ans on voit
bien qu'on est dans une période
d'austérité importante je crois que la
population du québec est très consciente
de ce qu'ils pensent des services
publics qui ne sont pas suffisants on
évalue que le coût d'une place en ch à
celle des pour une personne âgée varie
de 42 à 71 1000 $ par année alors qu'une
personne qui restent à domicile ne coûte
que quelques milliers de dollars au
gouvernement
le rang lui attend un coup de pouce du
clsc pour l'aider à prendre un bain
garden dallest les personnages qui donne
de l'aide
mais ce que veulent surtout monique et
leurs rangs c'est de continuer à vivre
ensemble dans leur maison où il habite
depuis 50 ans on sera encore on veut
rester un salon le plus possible
j'en fais les peurs robillard rebond
soir le ministre a réagi à guitares
barrette affirme lui que tout est à la
hausse les budgets comme les services on
va devoir concilier tout ça oui fx est
masqué le dit le ministre ce qui vous a
dit cet après-midi le ministre dans le
fond c'est qu'il n'avait pas avec son
gouvernement n'avait pas sabrer dans
l'aide à domicile dans les soins
infirmiers à domicile de ce qu'on
appelle en fait le soutien de missiles
les films que son gouvernement n'a pas
de chasse n'a pas ça brille au contraire
vous l'avez dit le ministre nous a dit
que le budget des soutiers du soutien de
messieurs augmenté tout comme le nombre
d'heures de soins le nombre d'heures de
soins qui consacré entre autres au
maintien à domicile des personnes âgées
a également dit que ça avait augmenté
genève et à l'écouté la réalité est que
quand on compare 13 14 avec 14 15 on
comprendra 14 kinsella dernières données
disponibles
on a au québec a augmenté de 11 % le
nombre d'heures de services donnés aux
personnes à domicile et on a augmenté
d'environ 8%
le budget c'est ça la réalité et on
parle du budget total de l'envelope
soins et oui c'est ce dont vous parliez
c'est une portion de cette enveloppe
l'axé l'aide à domicile l'aide à
domicile et c'est ça que là vous avez
les cheveux noir sur blanc
à montréal c'est ça qui a il ya eu on a
connu une baisse de 9% l'année en cours
ben oui c'est ça et là des domiciles
cellede aura pas l'aide au ménage et
l'inde aubin et là ce qui est beaucoup
demandé la parler les personnes âgées le
gouvernement le parti libéral à l'époque
en crampons électeurs l'avaient prévu
avait promis 150 millions de plus pour
le soin à domicile enveloppe totale on
en est où là est-ce que ce que dit le
ministre cet après midi c'est que cette
année il y avait 100 millions de dollars
dont qui avaient été injectés pour
améliorer les soins des messieurs vous
invite à écouter à nouveau le ministre
guette en barrettes au total au moment
où on se parle nous avons
augmenter d'environ 600 millions avec la
réévaluation des besoins et sur l'île de
montréal pour l'ensemble des services à
domicile pour l'ensemble c'est + 19 %
est ce que ne dit pas le ministre
patrice est intéressant c'est que le
gouvernement entend de plus en plus à
transférer tous les services d'aidé à
domicile vers les entreprises des
entreprises d'économie sociale donc
l'aide au ménage l'aide aux repas ça
serait effectuée donc par des
entreprises des entreprises de
l'économie sociale très bien mais en
tout cas il reste que les gens vous avez
rencontrées et s'attardait s'essuie mois
et les chiffres il ya une réalité qui
est là voilà merci on va y revenir de
toute façon merci beaucoup merci au
revoir